hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
time for the Monday morning podcast on
Monday sorry
for third hey no it is not the money
Wednesday Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday morning podcast and check
it it on you I'm just checking in on you
how you doing what are you what are you
done today how did you watch the news
did you fill your head up with all the
[ __ ] craziness on the news isn't it
great watching the news oh yeah hey I'm
waking up I'm feeling good you know what
let's turn on the news why would you put
on the [ __ ] news what are you going
to see are you going to see an accurate
portrayal of what's going on sticking
out the [ __ ] window how look at your
neighbor Hey look at him huh walking out
to his car with his little brown sack
with his [ __ ] lunch in it huh is he
saluting Hitler you know it's just as he
got a bomb strapped around his waist is
he got a mosquito on his head that's
biting him so he has babies with little
heads jesus [ __ ] christ the goddamn
the hysteria the hysteria that these
news organizations social media in all
of this [ __ ] has created like you just
mean I'm just I'm [ __ ] while I'm
walking away man
I'm walking away I'm done I don't need
to know what's going on I don't need to
be informed okay because walking around
in a constant state of [ __ ] hysteria
is I don't think that that is being
informed when my real my reality my
day-to-day is I get in a car I Drive to
a building and I write dialogue for
cartoon characters occasionally I get to
play drums I do stand-up I hang out with
my wife and is that by God everything
right I hang out with my daughter and
that's it but I put on the news and I
will literally think that there's a
glacier melting right above me that's
going to drown me polar bears are going
to
swimming and eat me with [ __ ] bombs
strapped around their [ __ ] waist
everybody [ __ ] relax [ __ ] relax
and all these people [ __ ] going on
there and they just so and so got on TV
and told Trump supporters I love these
people that like you know on these
[ __ ] news channels they go on and
they [ __ ] you know give the other
side a piece of their mind as if the
other side even sees it they're too busy
like watching their own [ __ ] and even if
they see your [ __ ] you're not going to
sway them I'd equated to all those years
I lived in New York City as a Boston Red
Sox fan during that time I didn't have
money for the baseball package so I used
to watch the YES Network I always
watched Yankee home games always home
and away whatever I rooted against them
the entire time I watched them
I watched more Yankee games from 1999 to
2007 than I watched Red Sox games so in
theory I should have become a Yankee fan
but I did not because I was a staunch
red freckled-faced Red Sox fan and
that's it so all these people going on
TV talking about these [ __ ] people
now these [ __ ] jerk-offs are going to
go up to Boston right you know 18
[ __ ] jerk-offs you know I know it's
more than that but everybody oh my god
and Nancy's taking over and then they're
going to show the [ __ ] footage of
Boston and bussing and all of that [ __ ]
but way back in the [ __ ] day it's
just a perfect storm of racism what I've
got is Hitler really dead when we return
his body was never found
according to reports there was an
angry-looking jerk-off riding around in
a mercedes-benz spotted just last year
down in South America I'm done with all
absolute [ __ ] stereo out there these
people are losing their [ __ ] minds
losing their minds screaming and yelling
at each other
nobody's listening to anybody
everybody's acting like the [ __ ] sky
is falling
one fat [ __ ] shoots off a [ __ ]
missile and everybody loses their [ __ ]
one missile we do that every [ __ ] day
but worried about this guy one [ __ ]
fat guy with I just don't understand the
level of [ __ ] freaked out that's
going on you know it's fine
Yankees are playing the Red Sox this
weekend all right
college football's coming up NFL
football baseball playoffs are coming
it's all going to be fine all right I
got to tell you there's always been Nazi
supporters and they've kind of always
had rallies but it's not like they're
growing you know what I mean are they I
mean I think I got to be honest with you
you don't get any whiter than me and
I've never gotten a flyer no one's ever
asked me to join I don't walk down the
street hey hey you know guten tag look
I'm not saying these aren't important
issues but I'm just saying be level that
people are [ __ ] freaking out all
right
just need to [ __ ] relax just [ __ ]
relax man
okay you can vote against whoever you
want to vote against very soon right
isn't it like midterm elections and then
there's this other [ __ ] you know what's
going to happen you know what's going to
happen okay this is [ __ ] country
going on way over here yeah we're going
back over here so anyways whatever how
you doing how was your Thursday
afternoon huh got good people in you
like jam a sandwich today I wasn't that
delicious was there a terrorist in your
sandwich was there a little Nazi flag on
the [ __ ]
pick that they stuck in your [ __ ]
knock club sandwich there I'm going to
say there wasn't I'm going to go out on
a limb and I'm going to say there was
I'm actually doing the Trump hand thing
right now when you put your index finger
and you on your thumb I like it the
other three fingers stick up you know
it's great about it you really feel like
you're [ __ ] driving your point home
I'm gonna start doing that with my
wife's okay tell you right now there's
going to be coke coke beer in the fridge
you know what the biggest crisis in my
life is right now is I I cannot [ __ ]
I cannot sustain a workout or eating
well for any significant amount of times
to prevent me from staying at the
[ __ ] weight or gaining weight I just
can't do it this [ __ ] writers room
you're just sitting in there with all
these people you love watching them
slowly die that's what it is because the
matter how few calories you eat you're
sitting on your [ __ ] ass for eight to
ten hours a day and you just can't you
can't [ __ ] do it I'm so [ __ ]
pissed at myself right now I'm gonna
have to start doing two-a-days I'm going
to workout in the morning and I'm just
going to have to like I don't know what
to do I went out last night and I did a
I did a show down at Largo and I stopped
eating it like you know I don't know
what the [ __ ] I didn't want to had like
five o'clock I don't even remember I had
for dinner 5:30 or something like that
well then I got down to the club and I
was hungry and I went to this vegetarian
restaurant those [ __ ] things oh I
didn't eat meat yeah but what did you
eat what was in that [ __ ] sauce you
know it's going right to your [ __ ]
ass right your stomach and then you know
I have one one whiskey that was it and
then I came home and I'm [ __ ]
starving
my wife had a little bit of Thai food I
had that and I'm just so I'm [ __ ] I'm
killing my side own I got it I got it I
don't know what happened to my
discipline I don't know I'm just under a
lot of [ __ ] stress right now I guess
that's why I'm having this reaction to
the [ __ ] news and everybody's
watching it and then they coming in and
then like can you [ __ ] believe this
can you [ __ ] believe this
it's just like all right you know the
grand the news I think if they showed
the amount of [ __ ] people last week
who didn't get in the car and plow down
a bunch of [ __ ] people like a
complete piece of [ __ ] that would be the
rest of us and this one [ __ ] [ __ ]
does it and then everybody starts
thinking is this what the world is going
to be like now is this going to have
this just how [ __ ] I don't know how
awful a [ __ ] parrot did that person
have Jesus Christ you know I think when
your kid starts putting like the Hitler
poster on the wall it's time to be a
little more involved maybe sign them up
for volleyball or something try to get
them out there you know I don't know
what you do with that is there a hotline
for that 1-800 my son's into Hitler
[Laughter]
1-800 I keep finding two holes poked in
the pillowcases you know what I mean
there's unconditional love and then
there's Hitler right who's kidding who
and then it's kind of like all right you
know what I think it's time to ship you
off to the loony bin and let's make a
new kid it's time to make a new kid son
you know what you're like an old star
it's time to go which you like Brett
Favre when he got shipped to the [ __ ]
Jets it's over for you it's over okay
you can't make the pass across the field
anymore you know what I mean you've lost
your vision and you got post as a Hitler
it's over we're trading you to the New
York Jets and we're bringing in a new
baby we're having a [ __ ] that's what
I would do if I be kid became a racist I
would [ __ ] turn my kid in and then I
would just make a new kid that's it I'd
you know go back to the draft you know
to me maybe adopt basically sign a free
agent you really have to have a strict
no Hitler [ __ ] policy in your house
you just have to have it anyways I saw
this thing where people were going on to
end white people going on and it
ancestry.com and we're not pleased with
some of the results yeah I mean that's
going to happen right it's going to
happen you're going to find a couple of
surprises in there that's going to [ __ ]
up [ __ ]
the Amana Festa you know I would love if
you did [ __ ] what the [ __ ] did they
do with Hitler anyways what I mean even
if he lived he's got to be dead by now
right what was that guy born 1890
something he's so evil like maybe he's
still alive
just the hate is keeping them going you
know just picture them with like a
[ __ ] SS Walker screaming with every
step trying to get to the [ __ ] toilet
you know to take a master race [ __ ] they
only just encouraged his painting if
that it only happened that you wouldn't
have all this craziness I used to what
they find something else anyways Red Sox
up down up down up down against this
week and uh Yankees I think they won
last night against the Mets so the Red
Sox Yankees played this weekend right
everybody's going to have a good time
enjoy the game I take me out to the ball
game take me out to the crowd buy me
some peanuts and crackerjacks
you know scan your fingerprints at
[ __ ] Tiger Stadium because you are a
[ __ ] dope so anyways I'm gonna start
doing two-a-day workouts that's what I
got to do it I just have to I have to
[ __ ] commit I'm trying to figure out
this new life that I have with this
[ __ ] writers room because it takes up
so much so much of my time that you know
I have a very finite amount of time to
[ __ ] work out and still actually keep
my stand-up act going and all this [ __ ]
I think it's causing me stress and maybe
that's the [ __ ] problem maybe I'm
just old I don't know I gotta fight it
dude I can't have the [ __ ] dad but
you know we just like just thick big
[ __ ] you stupid skinny arms coming
out beside that mr. Potato Head [ __ ]
body you know I can't [ __ ] do it I
guess also because I blew out my
shoulder which is finally the thing is
better now I'm going really slow I had
the the rotator
[ __ ] going on right so I'm now this
morning I actually for the first time in
like a year
I had the [ __ ] barbell and I was
benching and I had 5 pounds on each side
that's how long and slow this process is
and I felt like oh just a little
something and I was going to do 3 sets
and I said I immediately stopped which
is what you have to do with an interest
you have to immediately go you know what
[ __ ] this I'm not doing this anymore so
anyways let's let's you know let's let's
Google some news
Google cants cancels domain registration
for daily stormer alright let's see what
we got here Google has cancelled all
this is going to be more hate group [ __ ]
Justin Bieber may have been unknown 17
year old famous with a single picture
really a reporter calls out Huckabee's
claim that countless FBI employees were
that's like reporting now you just put
your headline is really three deaths
foods you should avoid death foods okay
alright let's just read this one let's
see we see we are canceling daily
Stormers registration with Google
domains for violating our Terms of
Service dispose person told Business
Insider well where the [ __ ] was this a
while ago you read Google's registration
agreement you can read it here okay
Google didn't want its service used to
incite violence a source close to Google
told Business Insider I don't know I
hate to do the cliche but when you those
[ __ ] white supremacist groups they're
just the dumbest [ __ ] people look at
this [ __ ] guy it's like if they
if they made a movie about white
supremists this guy went to the casting
I don't get people who go down and
protest the [ __ ] these hate groups
just let them go down there and scream
and yell to nobody you know what I mean
why do you go down there and then what
do you do you start tearing their signs
down as if they're going to be like oh
they tore our sign down now I see their
[ __ ] now I see their side of it all
you're doing is reinforcing in their
head that you guys are [ __ ] [ __ ]
you should go down there you should bake
them a little pumpkin pie little apple
pie and just give them some food and
just be nice to him and so we shoot that
[ __ ] guy that fatty over there North
Korea you know I'm Stromberg all that
smoke a cigar with them talk about
grabbing [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] you
wanted to do you know instead of you do
that we're going to do this all right
um okay I have to get out of this vortex
here I just [ __ ] Google News Boston
to hate groups you're not welcome here
you're not welcome here we got plenty of
my haters already here in Boston it will
be funny if other racists in Boston were
upset about the races coming here
they're going to take our hate to take
her jobs man dude we can't have a bunch
of other people coming up here dropping
the [ __ ] n-word or what are we going
to do then you're not wanted here dude
we're not hiring we got [ __ ] plenty
of them anyways uh what else what else I
got nothing going on dude I'm just
sitting in a [ __ ] writers room eating
salads and somehow putting on weight
because at the end of the day I [ __ ] it
up last night I was at Lago I got one
more show down there tonight I worked
for Joe bartnik and Todd rx2
so would [ __ ] beasts and they killed
it last night we're going to be down
there again tonight for a great cause a
friend of mine Pete coming unfortunately
passed away last year one of the great
comics that I met on the way up and just
a great guy so we're raising money for
his kids so I want to thank everybody
that came down there last night and
tonight raising funds doing something
positive
not being in Isis not being in a hate
group right something positive honey
when I told you I wanted you to be more
social I should have been more specific
that's a mom pulling up to like a Klan
rally yelling at her son Timmy I wish
you wouldn't do that
I really wish she wouldn't could you
just stop it I mean anyways I just can't
get out of the vortex of that
so anyways I'm all freckles is trying to
invest his [ __ ] money because the
government's taking all of it and I'm
sitting there trying to buy the smallest
of small little properties here so
someday when I'm in my [ __ ] 70s and
80s and I don't feel like going out on
the road unless I want to I don't have
to you know what I mean I don't want to
[ __ ] you know what I mean because you
know you what goes up comes back down
again and if I'd start the gentle slide
back down to doing the [ __ ] comedy
vault at Remington's in Boston when I'm
in my 80s which unfortunately that room
finally passed away like a year or two
ago about a year and a half ago the
comedy vault legendary room started in
1993 dick Doherty house spike Tobin I
was on one of the first nights there put
together my first five minutes right
down there right next to the [ __ ]
bank vault why am I thinking of that
[ __ ] because right now I'm trying to get
a loan alright and I have I should have
perfect [ __ ] credit but I don't
because I pay off my credit cards every
[ __ ]
so and they don't like that I paid off
my loans early they don't like that
dings your credit they look at that like
a loss like hey we were going to make
five grand off this loan you paid it off
twice as fast we only made 2,500 bucks
we lost 2,500 bucks on this guy so I've
given these guys every [ __ ] goddamn
piece of information they need I have
the credit I have the [ __ ] money it's
a [ __ ] joke
and then today they come at me they want
two years of my [ __ ] cell phone bill
now I got to dig through all of my [ __ ]
to try and find that and I just want to
say to them can you just tell me why you
need all this well these are the new
regulations but yes yes and why why are
these new regular whi do these New York
regulations exist well I mean that's
just something to know they exist
because you guys were irresponsible with
your own country men's money ten [ __ ]
years ago and you [ __ ] nucleic ahna
me I didn't do it I'm a responsible
[ __ ] guy I live within my means my
checkbook is balanced now I have to jump
through all these extra hoops why
because you guys are greasy greedy
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] that gave every
[ __ ] mouth breathing dope five
hundred [ __ ] thousand dollars came
walking through your bank doors for good
seven eight years in the last decade now
I got to sit here digging through
shoeboxes a [ __ ] phone bills you know
because you're a double secret probation
because you're a [ __ ] I love how
because they're a [ __ ] all of a sudden
it reverts back to me like now I have to
pay for this since will actually build
this defect if they're holding their
feet to the fire like this you know
that's a good thing for you and your
money because your money's tied into the
system I realized that I just wish that
when you say hey why do I have to do
this they don't hide behind regulations
they should say well because we got so
greedy ten years ago the culmination of
our greed ended up with the [ __ ] the
cooking of the [ __ ] economy and old
people thought they could retire then
had to continue working right into their
[ __ ] graves that's what the [ __ ] we
did with you money
hence we need to see the last [ __ ]
two years of your goddamn phone bill oh
we're taking callers all right let me
read a couple of advertisements here all
right all right
Indo cheeto Indochina Indochina I talked
about how every man looks better in a
suit I'll tell you you know what I mean
when I look at Paul Verdi I'm like this
guy's a [ __ ] animal you let you put
him in a suit I'm like holy [ __ ] I want
to hear what that man has to say he
looks a lot better look at him in that
three-piece suit and those Jordan threes
do the Jordan fries with the three-piece
suit dude endo keno is making it easy to
get perfectly tailored they perfectly
tailored suit at an incredible price you
can choose from hundreds of top quality
fabrics and personalize your suit just
the way you want it whether it's for
work a wedding or another special
occasion endo Chino has suited up
hundreds of thousands of men and are now
the largest made-to-measure menswear
brand in the world here's how it works
you drop your [ __ ] drawers and a
little fella comes in any message from
your ball bag down your ankle I'm sorry
visit a showroom or shop online and endo
Chino com pick your fabric what do you
want next to your Bulls choose your
customizations from lapels lapels
depletes the jacket linings and more
submit your measurements place your
order and wait for a robot of your exact
dimensions to arrive handing you a suit
in just a few weeks this week my
listeners can get any premium hey do you
think what the robots take over is going
to be like terrorist robot groups or
like racist ones hating on the other
ones the older versions this week my
listeners can get any premium Indo
cheeto suit for just three hundred and
seventy nine dollars at Indo Chino calm
when entering birbee you are are at
checkout that's 50% off the regular
price for a made-to-measure premium suit
plus shipping is free oh yeah you guys
going to look like the mulch you look
like Scary
the Ndoki know.com promo code bur for
any premium suit for $379 and free
shipping incredible deal for a suit that
will fit you better than anything off
the rack ever could
oh look who it is but who do me undies
me undies your sons into [ __ ] Hitler
doo doo doo doo it beyond DS beyond II
put his pants on and watch him take his
[ __ ] ler he's got a [ __ ] Adolf stache
what do you need nothing rhymes I'm
[ __ ] sorry [ __ ] I went with Hitler and
mustache stache he's got a Hitler
[ __ ] stache you're a dope you [ __ ]
white trash no one cares you're not
supreme you're just a bunch of [ __ ]
losers getting sunburns
everyone should just ignore them I love
that whole feeling that if you ignore
them that that's what exactly what they
did when they were in [ __ ] dirt now
this is different this is different okay
you don't have a fleece I argue that
this is different right isn't it
different it's completely different it's
a different scenario this country is on
top Germany wasn't you know I mean if
this country spiraled down in the
rankings you know like what happened to
the Michigan Wolverines over the last 20
years where they were they were this
powerhouse [ __ ] program and then they
just dropped out of sight flatlined for
15 years that's when that's when they
can take hold but you everybody
anybody's got their [ __ ] everybody's
walking around with Crocs right they got
that jag jagang zon everybody's got a
flat-screen TV everybody's putting on
weight like me it's a [ __ ] great
country so they nobody hears them I
don't think I'm just going to shut up me
undies okay you want to look good in
your underwear and be comfortable right
but that perfect balance is hard to find
yes your [ __ ] mushroom fat [ __ ] like
me talk about why me undies is the best
underwear you will ever own
feel free to improvise
um listen I just if you [ __ ] want
your balls to feel nice and soft okay
do you want to treat your balls right
basically the weak point in the
Deathstar that is the male body which is
the balls okay because I don't give a
[ __ ] how many [ __ ] weights you lift
how many [ __ ] kung fu classes you
take if you look in the other way and a
[ __ ] I don't care a little bunny
rabbit it's hopping by and its head
comes up and hit you in your ball bag
you're going down you tapping out the
fights over and you got a little bunny
sitting on top of you and he's the new
UFC fighting that in the blue corner the
undies will be the most comfortable pair
of underwear you'll ever own made from a
sustainably sourced natural soft fabric
that is three times softer than cotton
ultimate feel-good under use for when
you want to feel naked not be naked what
when you want to feel naked not be naked
what that doesn't make any sense
ultimate feel good undies so when you
want to feel naked not be naked oh okay
sorry for fellas hi the undies diamond
seam pouches cradles your jewels and
gives you stuff to support it needs
without feeling too tight plus it gives
it a nice little outline you flash your
light on it you like ladies is my junk
you know if you swing the other way
fellows like a rice ball bag right now
my undies has and I just realized my
mother-in-law's upstairs watching my
daughter [ __ ] tone this too and I
just screamed like a rhinestone baalbek
loquacious right now the undies has an
exclusive offer for my listeners get 20%
off your first pair and free shipping
there this this is a no-brainer to try
20% free shipping for 100% satisfaction
guarantee what are you waiting for
will you waiting for it to get 20% off
free shipping and their 100%
satisfaction guaranteed and the best and
the softest underwear you'll ever own go
to Mandy's comm slash for this limited
offer it is a limited time offer so what
are you waiting for okay start wearing
the best underwear of your life it
changed my life evidently it's time to
get me undies chained me undies change
yours it's time to let me undies change
yours go to me Ani stop calm / / right
now I got to get classes alright i'll
LegalZoom everybody it's its national
make a will month at LegalZoom and that
means it's time to take control of your
family and assets preparing for your
family's future is the most important
thing you will do this [ __ ] stuff
sure there's a lot of think about what
kind of bear you're going to drink what
kind of me undies you're going to buy
you're going to bedazzle your [ __ ]
balls with some jewels but other than
that what happens if lightning strikes
your ball bag when you're wearing your
bedazzled rhinestone me undies huh and
you've been you die oh your nuts are
cooked and you don't feel like a man
you're too depressed to work that's why
you need to make a will this month okay
but it's hard who wants to think that
hard well LegalZoom created an estate
planning kit to get you going go to
legalzoom.com slash prepare to get your
free kit you'll get a ton of helpful
info plus LegalZoom discounts all things
you need to stop procrastinating start
preparing you for your family's future
this is the greatest thing I ever did I
get a will right so right now you know I
give a [ __ ]
I'll [ __ ] walk right up to an
alligator what do you got buddy right I
don't care I'm covered LegalZoom design
designed this kit to provide the tools
you need all in one place whether a will
or a trust is right for you I do both I
have a will and a trust all right do not
revive me light me up do not bury me in
the ground that's it
sprinkle my ashes over a dumpster move
on I should actually say just put me in
the ground no coffin right there you go
no coffin just let me [ __ ] decompose
naturally feed the [ __ ] soil no dumb
it is that we actually you put a box in
the ground it's so [ __ ] stupid you
dead it's over but what if I still feel
something then you'd still be alive but
she did you know I chose people who
won't get cremated but they're going to
sit there late somebody [ __ ] drain
all the [ __ ] out of them take out all
your [ __ ] organs and then fill it up
with formaldehyde or whatever the [ __ ]
they do or you just get it over with if
you actually feel anything just be like
ah like a [ __ ] minute it happened it's
over
will you die again anyways if you have
any more questions you can always get
advice from their network of attorneys
available in all 50 states
since Legal Zoom is not a law firm go to
legalzoom.com slash prepare today
there's no obligation just great
resources to help you protect everything
you can get during national make a will
month that's legalzoom.com
slash prepare and I have to tell you
something if you're married and you have
kids you have to do that there's so many
guys out there just afraid of thinking
about their own mortality I have to tell
you it's it's a it's a weight off of
your chest alright because when you get
to my age you're going to see
unfortunately people dying who don't do
that stuff and how they leave their
loved ones is is the second tragedy you
know so don't [ __ ] do that to the
people you love
alright being dead serious here dead
[ __ ] serious no pun intended you got
to [ __ ] do that you got to take care
of them you're going to die [ __ ] deal
with it alright and God knows if you get
a woman in your life you're going to die
sooner rather than [ __ ] later with
all of the [ __ ] that they do they're
just you know they can't help it's just
what they are they give they love and
they take that's the balance you know
everything that they give your kid they
take away from you and then you just
slowly die this lonely existence in a
room full of other people and that is
the podcast for this afternoon kidding
that's every day Breanna was [ __ ]
around today on this podcast but
seriously stick your head out the window
you know just [ __ ] everybody relax
[ __ ] relax
[ __ ] Christ you can see the goddamn
people I mean they're too [ __ ] stupid
that too [ __ ] stupid to brush their
teeth they're going to run a country
anyway and why does everything always go
back to Germany - this is like Germany
in the [ __ ] 1930s well why is it like
Russia huh
why isn't it our country in the [ __ ]
16 17 and 1800s this wasn't exactly a
great place to live for a lot of [ __ ]
people
oh Jesus now I'm doing it I'm talking to
the [ __ ] I don't know what I'm doing
am I am i ranting and raving now I have
no idea all I know is I'm going to be in
a good mood today and I have to do two a
days two a day so I don't look like a
freckled Doughboy here I worked out this
morning you know I did my little half
hour on the [ __ ] an elliptical I threw
the weights around now the most crucial
thing is what I eat and when I stop
[ __ ] eating and all right so I
already got it tonight I stopped eating
at five o'clock I'm having a turkey
patty with the tabbouleh salad and then
that's it and then I have to drink
waters for the rest of the [ __ ] time
and then to make up for my sins last
night I'm going to skip rope for [ __ ]
three rounds you know try to burn off
some [ __ ] that way and maybe that's what
I'll do I'll do [ __ ] two days that
what I got to do I know what I got to do
I got to [ __ ] get out of this writers
room that's what I have to do and
instead of taking a lunch maybe I'll
[ __ ] bring an elliptical into the
office while we pitch jokes I'll just be
on the [ __ ] thing and everybody in
the writers room just takes a turn yeah
but every time you pitch a joke and it
doesn't get a laugh yo ten minutes on
the [ __ ] elliptical you know our whole
[ __ ] room will look like you know
they look at the end of the Tour de
France we just burn so many calories
like your body's like eating yourself
maybe going to the table reads by
episodes 8 & 9 being like yeah it's a
funny show but Jesus Christ if [ __ ]
I'm Asian what kind of show are we doing
here they put their heart and soul into
this [ __ ] thing oh wait a second all
of a sudden it got loud in my ears oh I
turned it up
pressed against it with my forearm there
all right hey by the way I got a new
band that I've been listening to and I'm
not going to remember the [ __ ] name
of them cuz I know my phone it's a
really weird name for a band
let me see I'm opening my [ __ ] iTunes
go to artists I know it begins with an A
this is getting everybody excited please
say my all J I downloaded this album
called this is all yours and I [ __ ]
love it
great album great album - chill out - I
listened I worked out to it this morning
cuz it was early in the morning it's
kind of [ __ ] you know you know creepy
and mellow and all that type of stuff
you know I guess I knew I was going to
get on the [ __ ] scale but uh I never
heard of them in Josh Adam is from the
goddamn comedy Jim he actually when I
was on the road he goes hey I'm gonna go
see this band tonight all J I'm like
what I thought it was a typo it's a LT
lowercase - capital J I really enjoyed
them and once again you math has a new
album coming out next month
alright that is it please listen to the
music little interlude here before we
give you another half hour of greatest
hits from a Thursday afternoon podcast
from a Thursday from a Thursday that
went by on a Thursday that you didn't
even pay attention to all right that's
it god bless you
thank you for not being an oxy and I
long have a great weekend your cuts and
I'll talk to you on Monday
right to be war the war is over and my
mother became a model for my violin
trumpet this the source of power lay
blame on your time with no party cuz
nobody
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
this is the Monday morning podcast for
Monday August 17th 2007 or 2009
why can't I have a decent date right I
actually this is the second time I
started the podcast because I always
just started and then I go to say the
date and I realized I don't know what
the date is
so I'm sick of doing that like I just
did that and I [ __ ] up the date I was
like I do this every time people going
to think it's a gimmick like I always
deliberately [ __ ] up the date so I
just hit stop
I hit a race and I started over again
and I [ __ ] up the year something wrong
with my brain you know it was because it
was the 17th then my brain was thinking
7 so then when I went to say the year I
say I said 2007 in case you're wondering
in case you're wondering anyways I'm
actually it's Sunday when I'm doing this
podcast because if you're listening to
this East Coast time in the morning I'm
on an airplane right now and I just got
a bunch of [ __ ] to do tomorrow so I
figured uh I'm not doing anything today
why not bang out a podcast you know
anybody can go out in Atlanta and hang
out with another human being you know it
takes a real secure [ __ ] loser to you
know still be in his [ __ ] hotel bed
at what the [ __ ] time is it
12:20 in the afternoon Jesus Christ
watch in the whatever the [ __ ] golf
major this is the PGA I'm actually
betting against Tiger Woods kinda have
this ongoing bet I keep betting against
Tiger Woods with another comic friend of
mine movies of African persuasion you
know basically because I've kind of not
been watching baseball lately I've been
trying to pick up new sports and the
only way for me to get into golf is to
have stupid-ass bets so I figure I'll
bet against not only one
bet against Tiger Woods I will bet
against Tiger Woods with another black
dude and I will you know just to make it
interesting you know say dumb [ __ ] like
dalsu white man's game I'm betting on
Ernie else you know what I actually won
in the [ __ ] masters I bet on Phil
Mickelson I won that one because he beat
Tiger Woods and I don't know I got busy
and I could have won another you know we
felt like 25 bucks a major I could have
won the US Open and I also could have
won the [ __ ] that one over there in
England and I blew those off and I think
I'm going to lose today it's weird I'm
betting against Tiger but you know my
money is but I'm actually rooting for
him you know is that exciting now I
don't think it is either
anyways let's uh let's plow ahead here
I'm gonna [ __ ] bad mood I had a really
had a really bad show last night
now I had a bad show I went up there and
I did this whole bit on Michael Vick
coming back and it killed and everybody
was having a great time and then at the
end of my said this this woman comes up
to me and you're like when someone's
going to insult you you know rather than
having I'm gonna insult you look on
their face they come up and they have an
ear to ear like Erik Estrada grin on the
face you know that's what she was doing
and she was just going like hi hi how
are you yeah yeah that whole thing about
Michael Vick yeah yeah did you really
believe that is that really how you feel
yeah and I immediately knew I'm like oh
god this is a dog lover here we go so I
was just like okay ma'am alright I'm
sorry I'm sorry I didn't like the show
you know they're just jokes if you want
to take him seriously go ahead and take
him seriously and then she's just
getting here yeah I get cuz you
statement she statements are really
ignorant yeah I just thought you should
know that she's like nodding and smiling
you statements are really ignorant it's
like first of all why are you smiling
you know that was the most annoying
thing not that she came up to me I mean
it's my own goddamn fault
I [ __ ] not only do I go onstage and I
say a bunch of stupid [ __ ] but then I
stand there like
idiot selling DVDs I'm opening myself to
somebody coming up to me and telling me
to go [ __ ] myself
I don't have a problem with that that
comes with being a [ __ ] [ __ ] who
sells DVDs at the end of his show
alright so I totally could have avoided
that so I'm not complaining about that
what I'm complaining about is people who
are telling you to go [ __ ] yourself
but they're smiling like is that
supposed to like mine [ __ ] me like I'm
going to like I'm not even going to
notice what you're saying like wow it
sounds like she's telling me to go [ __ ]
myself but she's smiling maybe I'm
hearing this wrong and then she's like
your statements are really ignorant and
she's nodding like you know what I mean
like that Bugs Bunny [ __ ] like remember
that when he wouldn't even be like no
the other guy be like yes no yes no and
at some point he would switch and go he
would switch over his [ __ ] argument
and the other guy would end up arguing
Bugs Bunny's argument that's what the
[ __ ] she was trying to do to me you
statements are really ignorant and she's
like nodding like I'm going to be like
yes my statements were ignorant so I
said lady so basically what you tell me
is because I don't agree with your point
of view that that makes me ignorant and
then she pulls this this thing she goes
I'm actually a member of the Humane
Society all right you know first of all
who the [ __ ] breaks out credits during
an argument
you know me she says it like I'm a
member of the Humane Society right like
it's supposed to be like this dumb dumb
dumb [ __ ] moment oh [ __ ] are you a
member of the Humane Society good lord
how many years of college did it take to
get that holy [ __ ] did you have to go
through medical school to become a
member of the [ __ ] Humane Society I
actually forgot ii was like wow i
actually thought that she was on the
board of the humane society first of all
i don't know what the [ __ ] humane
society is humane sounds like human to
me like you're into people but evidently
it isn't you're into [ __ ] animals
so i'm sitting here later on tonight
i'll [ __ ] annoyed with this lady
there's lady as jerry lewis would say
right i'm all [ __ ] annoyed with this
lady thinking like now i'm like wait a
minute she's a member of the humane
society
you know I was a [ __ ] member of the
[ __ ] is that that dead thing now of
course I can't remember
you know I'm thinking right now is how
[ __ ] up my brain is I'm thinking
Apocalypse Now Amnesty International I
know it was an a for some reason thought
there was a piece I was a member of
Amnesty International for like like two
three years you know that was against
torture and people around the world and
you know I became a member
I gave him 25 bucks I went on the
internet and I gave him 25 bucks I have
no [ __ ] idea what they did with the
money I don't know if they stopped
someone from getting tortured I don't
know if they just took that money and
they both you know a couple of them went
out to a movie
hey 25 bucks we'll go to the matinee you
know it's probably eight bucks each set
up for some popcorn to two tickets in a
popcorn come on dude we're not going to
stop torture so I did so let me go on
the [ __ ] Internet let me look up this
this uh this humane society and so I
went to it Humane Society org and sure
enough this is all you have to do to
become a member it's $19 a month or
whatever you can afford so I could give
these [ __ ] people a dollar a month
and then I too could walk around and be
a total [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then throw out my credit that I am a
member of the Humane Society and you
know what I'm going to [ __ ] join the
Humane Society at $1 so the next time I
do this Michael Vick pit when one of
these [ __ ] psycho people comes up to
me I'm in memory of the Humane Society
oh [ __ ] you know what so alright holy
[ __ ] I can't believe I didn't see at the
meeting oh that's right
neither one of us go to him there is no
[ __ ] meetings a member of your main
society you would have [ __ ] I can't
believe she threw that out like she was
on [ __ ] like she just did The Tonight
Show I'm the head of NBC you will never
get a show on my network that's the way
the [ __ ] she was saying it god damn it
it got worse it got worse so you know me
someone's being a [ __ ] to me no one
cannot cut me so you know I'm actually
upset with myself because I allowed her
make me mad as you can tell considering
it's [ __ ] 12 hours later and I'm
still and I'm talking about it alone in
my hotel room with the drapes pulled
closed this is how I always do it on the
road [ __ ] sitting around like Howard
Hughes yeah so then she goes you know I
remember that humane humane society and
blah blah blah blah blah and I said look
okay you know I don't know why do people
take comedy seriously
there was a stand-up comedy show I'm not
doing I'm I can't even begin to tell you
guys how many times in my act I say that
I'm a [ __ ] you guys listen to my
podcast you know I'm a [ __ ] actually
some people don't I had some guys send
me this [ __ ] email this week on Bill
for the love of God stop talking about
banks you sound like a [ __ ] read this
[ __ ] what do you mean read this [ __ ]
then it goes against everything that I
am I don't [ __ ] read and like I love
how you talked about those banks you
sounded like a [ __ ] and what when I
talked about the other [ __ ] I sounded
intelligent it's a [ __ ] podcast just
stand up back I don't I don't find buff
alright you know what look at here I go
again I'm allowing myself to get [ __ ]
worked up about this [ __ ] so anyways a
couple more back and forth go and then
she just realizes that I don't give a
[ __ ] I said something like well you know
what you should do ma'am is what I
always say when somebody just says that
they don't you know enjoy me and they
just want to keep telling me how much
they don't enjoy my act what I always
say to them I was like well you know
what you should do you should never come
to one of my shows again that'll show me
[Laughter]
so then she finally realizes that I
don't give a [ __ ] about a Humane Society
[ __ ] credit that she basically
purchased you know it's you know what
that again being a member of the Humane
Society is less respectful than when
they give some famous person an honorary
degree because at least this celebrity
didn't [ __ ] pay for it you didn't go
he'd go to Syracuse University org and
give 19 dollars so he could be like I
have an honorary degree from [ __ ]
Syracuse University
so anyways so that's what I said so
let's lady I you know you know what you
should do you should never come to one
of my shows again that will show me at
this point is kind of some people around
me that is starting to laugh so then
this girl just you know who's a member
of the Humane Society because she cares
so much
then just she just starts going for my
jugular she goes yeah well yes smiling
and nodding right this creepy [ __ ]
smile and this whole time - she's got a
clump of lipstick on her upper lip she's
one of these girls you could tell was
hot when she was in her 20s and now
she's doing the worst thing that you can
do is you're trying to hang on to it you
know so she looks like you know one of
the Real Housewives of [ __ ] Tupelo
Mississippi or wherever the [ __ ] she's
from right and she's going she's going
oh yeah yeah well you're doing great
right you're doing great you're here at
the punchline how you doing great I'm
like yeah you know shows kind of seem to
be selling well she goes now yeah it's
great you know yeah you're on HBO and
now you're here you know it's like lady
so are you you're here too and you
[ __ ] paid to come here to watch me
what is your [ __ ] point and she's
like and I didn't pay I didn't pay
whatever then she said something to you
if she started talking really then she
did that that that that thing you know
what how women have confrontations like
that was what they do is they stop
talking to you and then they start
talking to their friend really loudly
about you and she says yeah that guy yes
I can teach his [ __ ] the funny thing was
when she could have been more than five
feet away from me and she's yelling it
hey guys you're [ __ ] peaches [ __ ] and
then that's when I told it you know lady
you know I really didn't want to tell
you this but you got a big you got
something on your upper lip and I didn't
want to bring it up but now you're being
a jerk
and she goes it's lipstick I don't know
I don't even what happened after that
at that point I was actually mad and and
I don't know I kind of blamed the whole
evening on not drinking if you can
[ __ ] believe it you know because I
usually enjoy doing the road and now
this is my
third weekend that I've done where I
have not had a drop of alcohol and now I
finally understand why comedians want to
get off the road I never realized how
many [ __ ] morons there are out here
because I was drunk and I was part of
the problem but now now I'm sober I
think I'm talking about myself like I'm
actually a [ __ ] alcoholic I'm not I'm
just a [ __ ] lonely loser and that's
what I do I have a couple of beers talk
a little [ __ ] that's it bill denial
that's the first [ __ ] stage of it DJ
saying oh what a shot Jesus Christ from
the fringe oh you know what noise from
yesterday don't you [ __ ] hate when
you do that when you're watching sports
you ever done that in a sports bar you
looked away for a second you didn't
realize it was a replay from a month
again somebody hits a homerun you're
like [ __ ] aah
like the only guy now dude that was from
my last Tuesday they were playing the
Rangers and I got I thought those I
thought there was some now
you want another quesadilla um you know
I like about Vijay Singh all these
[ __ ] douchebags nowadays they're
trying to bring back that Rat Pack
swagger and you can't you can't do it
all right and the only guy I don't know
why I don't know why you can't wear
shirts the way they wore shirts back
then you can't wear that [ __ ] little
Bing Crosby hat the way they wore it I
don't know why I kept no [ __ ] idea
why Frank and white Dean and Sammy and
all those guys look so so [ __ ] smooth
I have no idea why but I was watching
this golf the other day I got a mitt
[ __ ] Vijay Singh he's got a little
swagger to him you know plus he said
that uh that hateful [ __ ] against women
you know which really lines up with
their generation remember that back then
once they just like beating their women
with the mop handle every time they
didn't have their roast beef and mashed
potatoes ready or some [ __ ] I don't know
what so anyways I've had a
trying to figure out why that lady
bugged me so much last night I you know
she was just I don't know I felt I was
pissed at myself that I got mad and I
was also mad at myself that I stand
there like a [ __ ] idiot selling DVDs
you know I don't know it really just
made me want to be like you know what
why don't I just go to the green room
after shows I'll do my shows and then
you know whatever I'll get an email and
you know I don't know you [ __ ] sit
there dance around like a monkey boy
from fifty fifty fifty five minutes I
don't even did an hour that show I can't
remember then they have somebody come up
to you just like and say that you're a
piece of [ __ ] because of a joke and then
they're a woman so you can't like you
know you know it was funny what she was
with a guy so the whole time she's given
me [ __ ] it's like I don't want to lose
so I'm giving her [ __ ] back but at the
same time I got to keep my eye on the
dude and also like not go too far
because then I got like a physical
confrontation with the dude which I
don't want to have him 41 years old last
time I had a fight
35 that was with my brother in a red
roof and that's an entirely different
story
and that doesn't count either because
your brother's going to stop at some
point because he has to answer to your
dad you know I can't [ __ ] remember
right ain't no tough guy I tell jokes
right so I don't want to get into this
guy you know it's funny the entire time
the guy had his back to me and he was
trying to get the woman out of the club
and that's the exact kind of guy who
goes out with a woman like that and vice
versa if it's a loudmouth douchebag guy
they always have a little mousy girl
because nobody who actually would speak
their mind would ever tolerate dating
somebody like that man a woman they
would be like I you out of your mind
you out of your mind right now you know
it's a joke guys telling jokes or
whatever you made your point I just
going to stand here screaming I don't
know I don't know it was a fucked-up
night then I had the next show I'm on
stage and I'm doing my act and I'm
having a great time and you know I
told the story about the woman I called
her a [ __ ] and I felt like I got that
out and everything was going great and
all of a sudden this uh this this this
lady just walks up to the stage I'm in
the middle of my ass she's like can you
can you can you say happy birthday my
friend has her it was like lady could
you act like maybe I'm [ __ ] in the
middle of doing a show at some point no
it's just it was a [ __ ] it was a weird
it was just a weird night and then after
that then I went over to the club 290
next door as I always end up doing and
this time this is the first time I went
in there and I wasn't drinking
and I realized how [ __ ] up that place
was it was just dude came up to me right
and this whole week I've really been
have a difficult time understanding some
of these who people who live outside of
Atlanta their [ __ ] accents this I'm
standing there talking a couple people
from the club and this guy just comes up
to me he's like will I'm like what he's
like will he's sticking his hand down
and I'm I thought he was saying like
will you like he would start the
sentence like will you stop standing
there will you buy me a drink I know
what the [ __ ] he was going to evidently
he was saying his name he was
introducing himself his name was William
buddies go will will and I was like what
alright but there's one of those bars
everybody's every other person seemed
like they were on [ __ ] coke and this
is just Peter and out I don't not from
[ __ ] I've had enough and I usually do
Thursday through Saturday and something
[ __ ] up happen this weekend when I'm
doing Friday Saturday Sunday and
somebody asked me this question last
week like asked me if sunday was a
depressing day on the road I don't know
if you listened to my past podcasts I
think I answered that yes it is
sunday is the [ __ ] worst you know two
shows Friday three shows Saturday you
know the big peak and you want to
[ __ ] leave and then you've got to
hang around the entire [ __ ]
a to do one more 50-minute set and then
you got to fly in on Monday which is the
[ __ ] worst you know I like flying on
Sundays you know flying across the
country everybody's still asleep they go
into Church you know they're waking up
from a hangover finishing that last
slice of Domino's I don't know what
they're doing but they're not on the
road driving so when I land at the
airport
I just grab my [ __ ] I jump in a cab and
I'm [ __ ] back at my place
you know you fly back on a Monday the
UPS trucks the FedEx guys are out there
right [ __ ] homeless people laying in
the streets it's just [ __ ] horrific
so anyways I had such a great week too
I had a great week you know one of the
people who listened to my podcast works
over at cap the Capitol Records place
and they invited me over there to go on
a tour which I did this past week and I
got to tell you was it was the greatest
tour of anything I've ever taken ever do
you remember Geraldo Rivera when he did
Al Capone's vault and everybody thought
it was going to be the greatest [ __ ]
thing ever remember how great you
thought it was going to be like what the
[ __ ] is going to be in that safe and you
were like there's no way this is going
to suck and it just didn't live up to it
whatever your expectations of that were
this was twenty times that it was
unbelievable the guy basically explained
it and I'm saying the guy because I
don't use people's names on this he was
basically explaining that the Capitol
Records building is basically a
functioning Museum meaning that there's
a bunch of [ __ ] that they're still using
that really should be in a museum I
walked into the room where Frank Sinatra
sang all those songs luck be a lady Dean
Martin olive they had Nat King Cole's
piano and they had this little metal
chair like yeah that's Frank Sinatra's
chair I'm looking at it I'm like that's
not [ __ ] Frank Sinatra's chair that
looks like it should be in an IPS class
I was like one of those science room
classes and later on in the tour he was
showing all these black-and-white photos
because I guess back in the day the
Capitol Records label had their own
photographer
took all these [ __ ] pictures and by
the way Frank and Dean never looked bad
at any moment day one picture of Dean
Martin eating a bowl of soup and he
looked like a [ __ ] million bucks but
anyways then you look at the photos and
there's that [ __ ] chair
they had a microphone over there that
said Frank I Anne it's Frank Sinatra's
microphone and then they just use it you
know I gotta just fight absolutely
[ __ ] blew me everything and I can't
even like they had like the Masters of
like the band you know that group like
they just had him laying not like laying
in the corner they were going to be
doing something with them and I [ __ ]
actually got to hold it in my hand a
master it was it was I don't know if
you're a music geek that is the that it
was the place to go and not to mention
later on that afternoon one of my
favorite drummers of all time Steve
Jordan was recording with some huge
artists and they actually you know it
sucked was they had already recorded his
drum [ __ ] so he was going to be doing I
get some some percussion [ __ ] and all I
wanted to see was his kit setup in in
the in the studio that's all I wanted to
see but I [ __ ] missed it by a day but
other than that I got to go on top of
the building you know like I was [ __ ]
Dice Clay and Ford fair line
unbelievable view it was it was the
greatest [ __ ] thing I've ever done
and I you know if I was more articulate
I could explain how awesome it was so I
want to thank everyone over at Capitol
Records for being so [ __ ] cool that
was the greatest tour of anything I've
ever taken and you ever want to come to
one of my shows if you bring 40 friends
I will still hook you up that's how
great that tour was so there we go look
at me I'm bringing it around to
something positive that [ __ ] [ __ ]
from the Humane Society oh wait a minute
I can donate by phone you want to hear
me do this let's see how easy it is to
[ __ ] join the Humane Society of
America do you think they answer on
Sunday do they make their people work on
Sunday
that's not very humane is it
three nine three nine all right let's
see if we can do this oh wait I'm going
to give my credit card number over and
you guys can't hear this what oh wait
the saying the numbers been changed or
disconnected I'll [ __ ] you compute a
woman I'm joining the Humane Society I
cannot [ __ ] wait for the next dog
lover to come up to me taking that joke
seriously I'm a member of the Humane
Society so am i I have your credit too
ma'am and I got it in the time that it
takes to write a check so stand down all
right and why don't you blot your
[ __ ] lips before you walk out of the
[ __ ] house um guess Phil Mickelson
that I you know Givens you got love
about Phil Mickelson that guy always
goes for the pinned you have an artist
that [ __ ] he just doesn't give a [ __ ]
and then he four putts the guy's on in -
and then he four putts so anyways let's
get to the podcast questions this week
the phone is vibrating you know it's
weird I am NOT drank and so long and I
still feel hungover because I stayed up
till 4:00 in the morning last night it
couldn't go to sleep so [ __ ] pissed
all right here we go let's get to some
of the stuff okay YouTube videos if you
would like a laugh this week for some
reason I only have one of them I don't
know why I know I got more I know I get
busy I fly around sometimes I [ __ ] up
this is actually a cool video watch uh
it's it's snuffbox boyfriend seems s n
uff snuffbox boyfriend scenes and I
think you'll enjoy that I got a couple
other ones but people will kind of send
me stuff that I just feel like they're
just classic um YouTube videos like who
hasn't seen that woman who you know she
stomps the grapes you know she's having
that competition and then she falls out
of the thing and then she goes oh oh oh
oh you know because you got the wind
knocked out of her and I know that
sounds like I'm doing a [ __ ] up
impression but that's exactly what she
sounds like
and if you don't believe me hey let's
let's [ __ ] bring up that video right
now shall we let's see stomp stomping
grapes let's see if that will work
did that just [ __ ] work of course it
didn't I really don't like typing with
one hand stomping grapes and I'm telling
you it's literally oh oh oh here we go
here we go listen how she does it just
fall off the [ __ ] thing shut up shut
up
all right here they go sorry I'm trying
to fast-forward to this
shut up
why can't you fast-forward these videos
better and now it won't [ __ ] play god
damn it you know what do I got to start
this podcast over again this is so
[ __ ] horrific go play there we go
there we go oh you know what go [ __ ]
yourself a plate later on while the damn
things gonna load up all right you know
I feel like right now I feel like one of
those news guys who I just threw it to
the field and then the story's not there
and I got to stand there smiling and I'm
like okay now there's nothing on the
teleprompter for me to read so I feel
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] all right let's go
to ass bill hey Bill I want to be a
stand-up my friends say that I am funny
I wrote down about five minutes of [ __ ]
I thought was funny and I did a little
stand-up back to my brother he laughed
and said it was great
I have dangerously low self-esteem in
myself and the fact that I don't usually
like to laugh at myself when I'm writing
jokes by myself I usually laugh at a
joke I tell when I say in front of
people and I realize how crazy it sounds
I live in a small town so there's not
really any stand-up clubs there is a
place called the coffee connection which
has an open mic there I am a little
nervous too
because I don't want to bomb and
completely destroy my confidence I have
to actually become a comedian I'm not
afraid to talk in front of people I just
don't want to [ __ ] up in front of other
people but here is where a bigger
problem comes in at my high school they
have a talent show around the end of the
school year if I got up there and did
[ __ ] and didn't make anybody laugh
everyone that didn't know me at the
school would think I'm some dusty [ __ ]
that just was up there for the attention
I think I would just use the classic I
was just [ __ ] around I wasn't even
serious lying but inside I would still
feel like [ __ ] do you have any advice
that could help me yes I do
all right first of all having low
self-esteem and sort of hating yourself
you have the foundation for becoming a
comedian you got to give yourself
permission to suck and you got to give
yourself permission to grow in the
beginning which means you have to go out
and you have to perform in front of
people that you don't know the last
[ __ ] thing that you want to do not
knowing how to do stand-up would be to
go on in front of your entire high
school I mean that you know what maybe
that takes that write to the fact that
you're even considering doing that you
have way more balls than I ever had at
your age okay so you're already [ __ ]
ahead of me and not to mention that
you're still in high school and you're
already starting it so I didn't start
doing stand-up till I was 23 almost 24
so you're way ahead of the game
there's no [ __ ] reason to put
yourself into that situation unless you
feel confident you know if you feel
confident you feel like you're going to
destroy who knows you might bang one of
them [ __ ] cheerleaders there but but
then that would probably boost your
self-confidence you'd be like well maybe
I'm not a douche and then you just get
some regular job and you never get into
show business
um but I digress no you got to give you
got a you know something I did stand-up
and for the first year I didn't tell and
none of my friends even knew I was doing
it I think one of them knew and nobody
saw me for the first year I wouldn't let
anybody come my family knew that I was
doing it and I would not let any of them
come out to see me do it
and I didn't let my parents first saw me
I started in March of 1992 and my
parents first came out to see me
in March of 1993 and I've always been
blown away by comedians they'll go there
first time ever on stage and they invite
everyone from their office to come down
the place where they work to watch them
do stand-up and I'm just like dude do
you realize what it's going to be like
if you [ __ ] bomb and you have to go
to work the next day I mean why would
you set yourself up I mean it's just I
don't know so what I would do my advice
to you is is first of all don't worry
about having low confidence or low
self-esteem or whatever the hell it is
you don't have to worry about that your
confidence will build as you do it but
what you have to do is just you just go
out and go do open mics you'll get in
the click of other open my curse you'll
make some friends and then you become
like this little platoon you know and
it's like you against the world okay and
everybody's going to bomb all every all
your open microphones are going to bomb
you're going to bomb you're all going to
[ __ ] do it it sucks but it's the best
stories you'll ever tell in your life
and later on your career you're going to
look back and tell some stories I mean
I'll tell you know it would be a hell of
a [ __ ] story is if you went up in
front of your entire [ __ ] high school
and you ate your balls I mean that's
some [ __ ] like later on in your career
if you you know if you were starring in
a movie and you needed a panel story to
tell on Letterman or [ __ ] Conan I
mean that would be a hell of a one to
tell so that's I mean it's hard for me
to tell you what to do as far as whether
you should do that high school show or
not all I can go is with with my gut the
fact I got like scared reading your
email thinking about just putting myself
in your position of like just picture
myself at 17 18 if I ever went on in
front of my high school and tried to
tell jokes I mean I probably there would
have been a bucket of blood above me and
would have poured down on me just like
that movie carry it
would have been bad you know I got a met
halfway through that I would I just
thought what if I killed them you know
see you like a junkie
you just keep [ __ ] chasing it alright
so don't worry about it man just [ __ ]
have fun go out sign up for some open
mic so just do it in bars where they're
showing football games and no one's
looking at you and you just learn get
tough that way that's what I would do
you know and if you want to do the high
school show by all means [ __ ] go for
it personally I wouldn't do it but that
but I'm coming from a place of fear so
you know you got the balls go ahead and
do it but if you do it I want to hear
the results so please email me back
alright but other than that don't worry
about you know second-guess in your
material all that stuff and thinking
stuff sucks that's just a part of it in
the beginning okay if you think you're
awesome when you first start out you
usually end up being a hack you know and
you're out there you know what's the
deal with local jerks and I'm [ __ ]
great alright I hope that helped you out
okay alright any eyes next question bill
um I want to ask you about how you felt
about parents taking their kids on
planes recently I had a flight to Denver
back from Los Angeles not a long flight
but I was absolutely exhausted and
looking forward to the two hours of not
talking to people and hoping to maybe
catch a nap I had no such luck a young
couple with their two-year-old brat sat
behind me and proceeded to let their kid
kick the back of my seat and scream
repeatedly it was awful I don't blame
the kid two-year-old kids they stay kick
and scream that's what they do but the
kids parents did nothing to control
their child other than saying you
shouldn't do that what really pissed me
off
was that we were when we were landing
they were asking their child what he
wanted for dinner and this is written in
capital letters are you [ __ ] kidding
me
two-year-olds don't get options twelve
year olds don't get options twenty year
olds don't get [ __ ] options if
they're living in your house and you're
paying for everything as we were getting
off the plane I was hoping these people
would have the decency to apologize for
their kid kicking the back of my seat
but of course they didn't I thought
about telling these people that they
ought to both get they ought to both get
fixed because they were absolute
[ __ ] and all they were doing was
raising another absolute [ __ ] and
adding one more to the [ __ ]
population but I kept my mouth shut
because people like that see nothing
wrong with their behavior so what's the
[ __ ] point anyway have you ever have
you ever experienced an experience life
like this did you think about saying
something did you actually say something
all right
a great question I can be honest with
you when I'm on a plane and a kid starts
crying I don't know why I can't explain
it
but it makes me laugh and it makes me
laugh watching other people get [ __ ]
annoyed because I know somewhere along
the line I just sort of let go of that
it's like look these people they have
kids just like you said they can't
control them and that's it but I will
tell you this if you have a kid and it's
in the [ __ ] thing because the
two-year-old it's not a person yet it's
a [ __ ] thing the [ __ ] thing is
kicking the back of the seat of the
person in front of me in front of you
you have to do something about that all
right they got a little short little
[ __ ] legs at that point all you got
to do is just scoot them back and they
won't be able to they won't be able to
kick the back of the seat now I might be
[ __ ] ignorant here because I never
had a little two-year-old thing and I
might be oversimplifying this because I
really have sympathy for for people in
that situation man I don't worry what
he's supposed to do I mean in a perfect
world you could just knock the kid out
but you wouldn't want to do that it's a
kid you can't punch a kid I mean you
can't but then you'd have to talk to
somebody from the [ __ ] Humane Society
of well and you know what the [ __ ] I'm
saying you know what I mean
perfect world you could just tie into
the seat you would move but you'd
psychologically damaged with them and
you know damage the kid then you got to
live with them for at least another 16
years before he [ __ ] moves on to
Community College so have I ever said
anything no I have never said anything I
wouldn't I would never say something
like you know you know to if you want to
fail I also like when the planes landing
you like when you here's a pop and like
little kids they don't know what to do
they don't know what to do but I've
definitely given some people some not
even like what the [ __ ] I give them that
look like really you just kind of let
the kids sit there
and this is another thing too if your
kid is freaking out if you're just
making a [ __ ] effort even if you
can't stop the kid from freaking the
[ __ ] out just make an effort this is
where I'm gradually agreeing with this
person more and more just make a [ __ ]
effort that's all when people are just
sitting there and letting the kid cry I
mean I don't know if they're doing an
experiment because I've heard like like
you pick a baby up every time it cries
and it learns okay all I have to do is
cry and then I get discomfort if you're
trying to retrain them I don't know if
you got to retrain them could you do it
at home
I think they should sedate kids there
you go yeah I just said that you know
just come in with the [ __ ] have one
of those [ __ ] World War 2 psycho
doctors just come in with an
old-fashioned needle you just drugged
them up or maybe they could have like a
[ __ ] a glassed-in area do you guys
ever have that like the crying room in
church you'd put your kids way in the
back and they'd just be behind glass you
know so they wouldn't interrupt the
priest scaring the living [ __ ] out of
you that you're going to be going to
hell maybe they should have that down by
the luggage um anyways so no I've never
said anything yes I've wanted to say
some things but you know by the end of
it you know when you're actually going
to say something the flights over
anyways and that's a part of flying
isn't it some kids screaming anyways
alright um what am i moving on to the
next part of the podcast oh wait is this
video load it up yet number my
impression oh oh oh okay here we go here
we go
see I told you I lose that own you know
what that was that's the first time she
ever got the wind knocked out her so she
didn't know what to do that's what I
sound like when I was five the first
time that happened to me and the first
thing you learned is when you get the
wind knocked out of you is to shut the
[ __ ] up because every anyone if you try
to talk when you get the wind knocked
out of you that's what the [ __ ] you
sound like so you learned Hey afterwards
once you get your breath back you're
like wow I really sounded like a [ __ ]
idiot and I was going to do you know you
just [ __ ] can anybody explain that
phenomenon what is that and why no
matter how hard you're trying to breathe
in does your breath keep exhaling or
just pushing out you know it's like when
you when you yeah it's like you're
having a dry heave but you're not puking
you know just for those of you like a
held I dated a girl one time she was
like 27 years old she'd never had the
wind knocked out of her in her life
which I thought was one of the most
adorable things I'd ever heard now I was
like she was living under glass or
something but anyways uh why is you know
you know any [ __ ] times that happened
me as a kid that was like what we did me
and my had four brothers as we did as a
kid
that's what you did and your brother
wasn't paying attention you didn't have
to do it hard that was great you just
gave a [ __ ] rap right in the stomach
and then [ __ ] oh [ __ ] it here so um does
all the wind literally go out and why
can't you just why can't you just
breathe in why am i acting like you guys
have [ __ ] doctors why this isn't just
a bunch of truckers just forget it
don't you know what I want somebody to
attempt you know what have two people
who are going to [ __ ] answer this
question are going to do exactly what
I'm going to do at the end of this
[ __ ] podcast which is just look it up
and then give me the Wikipedia reason
all right here we go here's some
questions for the week bill on a
different not that's what someone just
wrote I think they wanted to say note on
a different not I was wondering what did
you think of the song
O'Reilly by the who I recently started
listening to rock music and I thought
that this song was incredible is it or
am I just some dumb [ __ ] no you're not
you're a young kid and you're
discovering the WHO and they are the
[ __ ] I would get who's next I would get
live it leads start with that just just
surf the internet they got some great
[ __ ] dear bill how much drinking do you
typically do during the week you're out
on the road all of the time working
places that serve booze and it seems
like it would be tempting to drink
pretty often out of boredom and
loneliness I think I already to answer
this at least I could see myself doing
that if I were traveling comedian is it
tough to avoid being a lush uh yeah it
kind of is you basically become an an
alcoholic out of like proximity you know
it's just there it's one of those deals
where you know I don't know if you were
in a bar four nights a [ __ ] week I
would think the odds of you drinking
would would go up exponentially yes I
just said that so yeah it is it is hard
to not tonight drink I already answered
this [ __ ] you know I don't know by
that's how it's [ __ ] boring as hell
to be out here it this this not drinking
has actually put me on edge I mean you
should the way I've lived this week out
here in the road if I live my entire
life like this I could run for president
and I wouldn't have to hire that I
wouldn't need any hush money
okay I've worked out the first day I
went to the grocery store I bought food
I got a little fridge here I've been
eating healthy I went to the gym every
single day I even brought my little
practice drum pad thing with me [ __ ]
around learning some rudiments I wrote
jokes eat okay I looked at some internet
porn all right right there that that
would [ __ ] lose a governor toriel
[ __ ] race gubernatorial however the
[ __ ] they say it but you know that's the
last thing if I could just cut out the
[ __ ] internet porn
I would be completely bored that you
know I gotta tell you that's what I am
right now I am sober right now and I am
not feeling this this unbelievable
[ __ ] high of like wow I can't believe
all this [ __ ] I'm I was missing all I'm
thinking right now is I can't believe
how [ __ ] long the day is you know
thank God I stayed up until 4:00 in the
morning last night so I didn't wake up
until 11:00 you know then you end up
feeling like a loser cuz now it's
already [ __ ] won I don't know I think
I'm done everybody if I don't drink I
don't think I can do the road anymore
and I don't think I'm gonna be [ __ ]
selling DVDs after my show I just I'm
not [ __ ] doing this anymore I'm gonna
be stoned [ __ ] sober and just seeing
a mirror image of what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
I've been all these years
alright overrated underrated I don't
know that I actually got any this week
so I actually threw in a couple of mine
I probably got some and I just what
stuff during the weeks I traveled to try
to save all these [ __ ] emails between
my blackberry and this computer here so
overrated
I say expensive jeans I remember when
you know if you had a pair of Levi's you
were cool you were in the club right and
what were they thirty forty bucks and
then people all of a sudden diesel jeans
that was the first expensive jeans I
remember and this this girl is talking
me into buying in and they were like 180
bucks 160 bucks this is the analysis
like eight years seven eight years ago
I'm like hundred eighty dollars for a
pair of [ __ ] jeans is ridiculous
I got like four or five pairs of Levi's
and she says like no but you'll see the
quality's better they last longer and
you know what they don't I think they
look a little better
I think nice jeans look better like at
this point then like you know this I
mean I think we can all agree there's
nothing worse than gap jeans you know
and they have like that sort of not
quite stone washed look to them but you
know they just look you just look broke
I notice a lot of white dudes in like
their their 30s and 40s will be wearing
those and they'll have like a
button-down sort of like I'm going to go
see Jimmy Buffett shirt on and they'll
tuck it into that and then I'll have a
pair of dirty white all white
Seinfeld sneakers on and it is just like
while dude you are [ __ ] married with
children because that is if ever there
was the anti [ __ ] that is the anti
everything that is just the asexual
outfit that you could possibly be
wearing so I've been one of these guys
who get sucked into buying you know more
of these expensive jeans and these
[ __ ] things they wear out they wear
out just like you wanting you want to
make your jeans last you got to buy like
[ __ ] five pairs and you got to
revolve them that's how you make them
last but if you're wearing them you know
every two to three days like I do like a
[ __ ] I'll tell you notice the most
filthiest [ __ ] out there are
musicians I can't believe I forgot to
tell this story right last week when I
was flying back from Providence Rhode
Island I decided to upgrade to
first-class
I just said [ __ ] it you know I'll deal
with the the [ __ ] credit-card bill
there's one of those deals where I just
didn't want to fly and I'm so sick of
[ __ ] flying and they were like hey do
you want to upgrade to first class and I
was like of course I do and they go well
we're just going to put our Virgin
Island [ __ ] airline dick in your ass
and I was like you know what I don't
give a [ __ ] guy and raped me I want to
[ __ ] sit in a lazy boy the entire
[ __ ] ride across the country so
that's what I do
so I'm sitting down and on the plane
comes this skinny dude with his big
titted girlfriend and they're like is
there any way you could switch seats
with that so we could sit together and I
was like apps are [ __ ] lovely if I
was in coach right now give you a dirty
look and get may give you some sort of
[ __ ] I'm superstitious I'm not
changing my seat [ __ ] you and you love
affair but I was in first class so now
I'm affable absolutely why absolutely so
I walked over and I sat in my seat and
they were [ __ ] sitting there the
first thing this dirty-ass magician does
he's got these flip-flops on right and
his [ __ ] toes it looks like you know
now I know why people watch Jesus's feet
that's all I can [ __ ] tell you okay
this [ __ ] guy he looked like he
looked like a bird of prey that's the
only way to describe his [ __ ]
toenails and everything and he did the
most disgusting [ __ ] thing I've ever
seen a human being do halfway through
the flight this [ __ ] gets up
to use the bathroom on the airplane and
I'm going to say that Airport airplane
bathrooms are some of the dirtiest
[ __ ] bathrooms ever just from
turbulence alone and the fact that it's
so [ __ ] cramped this dirty
[ __ ] he got up in his bare feet
and just walked into the bathroom in his
[ __ ] bare face
I couldn't believe it I was just said
does there's no [ __ ] there's no [ __ ]
way
there was no [ __ ] and he just walked
right in there I mean he should have got
a tetanus shot when he came out I
couldn't [ __ ] believe it how filthy
is that you know what kills me women
love [ __ ] love musicians absolutely
love them cannot get on their knees
quick enough to jump down into their
crab infested pubes and stick that
[ __ ] Reed in their mouth you know to
give a [ __ ] could give a [ __ ] about
comedians what women doing at the end of
the comedy show they come up and they
say you're a loser for the place you're
[ __ ] working in and then talk about
what a piece of [ __ ] you are really
loudly which brings me to my underrated
underrated for the week learning how to
play an instrument unbelievably
underrated you know because you really
stick with it you can get in a band and
I even if you suck you're going to get
some [ __ ] and and if not it's it's just
it's so much better than reading and
it's better than you know you read what
are you doing you know you're getting
smarter so what are you making the
person's day next to you better you're
not if you actually learn how to play
guitar you can play drums or something
like that I don't know I just think it's
I think it's a great [ __ ] thing you
know I'm actually excited because I
actually you know I told you guys about
this Les Paul guitar and by the way God
rest his soul
you know Les Paul died this week and I'm
really bummed I never got a chance to
see that guy that guy was still playing
shows every Monday night in New York
City and when I was back in New York for
the month of June I actually tried to go
see the guy and unfortunately the night
I was open where I could go see him he
was he was
performing that night so I didn't get a
chance to see him and I'm really sad
about it because I don't know that guy
is legendary I'm trying to see who I
would put that guy up with I'm he's
right up there with for me anyways all
the inventors I'm so stupid
Jesus Christ bill you gonna put him up
there with Einstein the light bulb
because the guy [ __ ] did some of the
guitar you know what I've done it in my
world is important if you guys if you're
not if you're not into if you don't play
an instrument or anything like that just
just Google Images for a Gibson Les Paul
and just look at how beautiful that
guitar is it's lit it's literally a
[ __ ] work of art and even if I didn't
attempt to play guitar I think I would
still own one rather than going out and
buying a painting I would actually buy a
Les Paul because that's how [ __ ]
beautiful they are
but anyways I'm actually learning how to
play guitar and last week I discovered
drop D tuning and it might have been the
greatest sound I think I've ever
produced as a human being on that Les
Paul it just [ __ ] sounded
unbelievable and I can't wait to get
back to my apartment to take out that
guitar to not read to not watch TV and
be informed on what's going on in the
world so I can continue to sound like a
[ __ ] on this podcast so some people can
continue to take me seriously and tell
me how [ __ ] dumb I am even though
that is my point of view what am I
talking about alright let's wrap up with
this now you know we have to do we
actually have to hype some of my [ __ ]
okay and by we I mean me I need to get
better at this type of stuff alright and
this is what I am going to be hyping for
the rest the biggest date that I have on
the horizon for me believe it or not is
my improv gig in Ontario California okay
I live in Los Angeles and I'm not able
to perform out in the LA area because I
have not shown to the club's that I am a
draw you know it's a little weird I got
I got to get on the Latino radio
stations out there so I can get
you know a significant portion of the
population to at least kind of know who
the hell I am because you know I don't
want to get on a [ __ ] plane every
other week I just don't want to do it
snowy either once a while I would like
to [ __ ] you know just be able to get
in the car and drive like I did when I
lived on the East Coast I Drive down to
Philly I Drive up to Boston I take the
[ __ ] train down to DC you know so
anyways I have this gig at the improv in
Ontario California
it's a from September 17th through the
20th for the love of God can you and 58
of your closest friends buy some tickets
and come out to that show I never beg
people to come out to my shelves maybe I
do but I don't grovel
right now I'm groveling for the love of
God please show up to that show so I can
somehow just have one weekend
during the year when I don't have to
[ __ ] you know just be sitting there
in row 33 you can't you please this is a
very full flight all of the overhead
space is going to be used up so if you
have one of your smaller smaller
containers if you could just put it
underneath your seat and please don't
put your jackets in the overhead
compartments this is a very full flight
and you know what everybody [ __ ]
blows it off and they're sticking
lunchboxes and fur lengths [ __ ] full
length [ __ ] coats as the ladies
saying that so just once our flying time
is four hours in 58 minutes I would just
you know every once in a while would
like to not have to [ __ ] listen to
that so I could just perform in in
California so for the love of God could
you Southern California people I know
you got a lot of options for the love of
God can you come out to my show thank
you all right
other dates I have in September I'm
going to be in Philadelphia the City of
Brotherly Love
do you guys beat the Braves last night I
know that [ __ ] was going on what do we
got here helium comedy club I'm going to
be there from September 10th through the
12th and I got a big date coming up
in the improv Addison Texas September
24th through the 26th possibly the 27th
because I think I'm hanging around on
Monday night because the Cowboys got a
football game and my life is awesome and
I'm going to go to the [ __ ] game and
I'm going to look at those [ __ ]
blonde big-titted [ __ ] Dallas [ __ ]
with their Mary Kay Cosmetics you know
who likes those broads is that guy from
the Playboy
the Playboy what the [ __ ] his name
that Hugh Hefner you know he's really
into that tex-mex not text messed up in
Tex Arkana Oklahoma that big round pie
face [ __ ] bleached blonde looking
girl you know you know those girls I'm
talking about
hey you how you doing how y'all doing
those [ __ ] girls do you guys watch
that show that show when he had those
three girlfriends I only thought one of
them was hot the other two were kind of
a mess
you know the athletic one she was
[ __ ] smoke and that girl was hot
and those other two girls I had
absolutely no use for him you know just
cuz you dye your hair blonde and you're
in shape doesn't mean you're
good-looking um all right I know I got a
lot of [ __ ] nerve balding redheads
[ __ ] throwing down like that alright
let's let's [ __ ] get on with it all
right that's the podcast for this week
that I did on a Sunday and I'll be
uploading this thing as I always do
right around midnight just to make sure
that I never post them on a Sunday if I
posted it on a Sunday then it would be a
very special Monday morning podcast and
this one isn't special this was sort of
me bitching which is sort of the
standard so anyways I hope you guys all
have a great week once again thanks to
everybody over at Capital Records to let
me take a tour of the building I you
know one of the greatest things I've
ever gotten to do all seriousness and
please come out to my shows the next
show I have coming up is in Stockholm
Sweden so if anybody overseas is
listening to this if you live in
Copenhagen Denmark evidently you can get
in your car and drive to [ __ ] Sweden
now huh or at least I just discovered
you could you go over that bridge then
to the island and into the [ __ ]
tunnel so why don't you come on over and
watch me talk my [ __ ] that is all the
date is October
August 29th what I'm doing it all right
I'm done babbling you guys have a good
week all right take it easy
we have taken to the streets and open
rejoice we all we are back wall
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
with letters as a picture
black-and-white free wrong with the
generator
[Music]
don't that make me modern worth
discussing and my own birthday
you're no botanist nobody is right three
Twilight love poison Katya
[Music]
we are waiting on a telegram to get us
new socks I am sorry to report to you
Karen
all we have taken to the treatment Oh
cat rejoice creeping we are back there
parrot is
[Music]
Oh
that
[Music]
Oh
Hey
[Music]